Hà Nội đang lối mặt Nguy cơ thường nghiêm trọng quyết đó cho bại độ xe và trọng xác.
Trong bối cạnh lộ trình, cấm xe mấy săng vào vình đại một từ tháng bẩy nắm hành hình khu trọng hay sấu được đầy nhàng.
Theo lộ trình được dau, thành phố phải bổ sung các điểm cho dữ xe và phát triển hạ tầm xác liệt để đáp ứng yêu cầu dí chuyện,
khi lượng lẫn phương tị xác bị hạn chế.
Hà Nội dự kiến bổ chí tối thiệu mười lắm vình trọng chỗ đổ tại các bái trong vình đại bà,
có chạm xác trước năm hành hình khu trọng bà mười, đồng thời khảo xác một chăm mười bị chỉ đặt chạm xác tập trung,
và nghen tíu mô hình đổi bình cho xe điện hải bánh.
Thuy vậy, các chiên gia đình giá, diểm ngạn lớn nhất của thành phố là quy đất dạo thống tính,
mới đặt không phải bà không phải muốn phần trọng diễn thích đồ thi,
thấp hơn nhiều so với tiêu trình bà để muốn phần trọng.
Nguy cầu vì xe của người dân ngoại thành và tính lên tận khi vào khu vực vành đại một được dự báo tăng mạnh.
Châu khi các đuyến vành đại một thay, thiếu mặt bằng xe bại đổ quy mô lớn.
Nếu ý kiến đề nghị thành phố hỗ trợ giải phó mặt bằng giảm chí vì đất cho đơn vị đồ đưa bài đổ,
chạm xác, tận dụng đất công công chưa dụng, và giá chí tiêu xe dụng chạm xác xuống tình phường xác,
việc bảo đam ăn toàn tại Trung cư cố, thống nhất tiêu trình bình và kìm xót xác thái bình cũng được nhấn mạnh,
giám tạo nền tảng cho các chiên trình đổi xác phương tệ xác.